the school of life is a YouTube channel
online business and physical school that
professes to teach people about
philosophy and emotional intelligence
but unfortunately they fall far short of
their own standard to the point it's
almost offensive the problem with the
school of life is threefold
they pretend to be unbiased they are
selling a shallow narrow view of
philosophy and they are relentless
profiteers in the worst possible way but
first who exactly is the School of Life
I say Who because while many people work
for the School of Life one man in
particular the founder is a main creator
of most of their content a lawn to baton
if you're unfamiliar with Holanda batons
work he's a sort of self stylized pop
philosopher but his works are really
more something like opinion pieces on
life with a ragtag assortment of
philosophy sprinkled in some of his
works include how to think more about
sex art as therapy on love if you're
thinking that he already sounds closer
to Oprah than he does to Aristotle
that's not far from the opinion of many
others Ilan is a polarizing figure using
disrepute by many philosophers as well
as many book reviewers who both
criticized him for lowering his books to
appeal to a mass-market crowd on the
other hand his books have been widely
sold and the school of life his
brainchild boasts one of the biggest
audiences for any philosophy channel on
YouTube and Ilan is important to
understand because he is the father of
many of the ideas peddle from the school
of life but now that we're clear on
who's behind this let's get on with the
problems of the school of life number
one they pretend to be unbiased and this
is what started my dislike of the School
of Life they pretend to be unbiased
while actually having a very particular
worldview and perspective on philosophy
here's such a claim in their intro video
what is the school of life so we built
the school of life an open-minded
rigorous on ideological organization
let's hear that again an open-minded
open-minded and uh Nydia logical but
then when you click on their videos all
you get is a constant stream of Ilan's
values and thoughts without even the
slightest critique of them as an example
our open-minded and untidy illogical
organization has this to say about
children it's almost a biological rule
kids will kill the relationship that
produce them I don't know where Ilan
gets this massive chip on his shoulder
but not all kids or harbingers of doom
to a relationship but maintaining his
status of being unbiased Ilan also
manages to quash several millennia of
debate with this nuance an ideological
statement about
what religion teaches us isn't about
what's true but about what many of us
here on earth desperately want to be
true open-minded rigorous on ideological
organization religious beliefs are of
course technically false but they're
coming from a very tender or
invulnerable place which needs our
empathy of course atheists are
technically right but there's no point
getting maddened by the apparent
irrationality of the religious pack up
your bags boys a lawn in the crack team
of philosophers at the school of life
have it all figured out and I want to be
clear I don't have a problem with the
school of life producing a video like
this that welcome to their opinion but
don't tell your viewer that you're
open-minded and uh 9.d illogical so
while the school of life claims to be
unbiased
they make videos that give a singular
narrow ideological answer to some of the
most important philosophical questions
at their best this means they're
self-deceptive and saying that they are
biased at worst they are deliberately
misleading their audience in order to
gain the appearance of objectivity and
in this one point I think a lawn just
might be a philosopher in the definition
of Nietzsche himself Nietzsche had this
to say about philosophers and their
prejudices philosophers they're all
advocates who do not wish to be regarded
as such
generally astute defenders also of their
prejudices which they dub as truths
problem to their selling bad philosophy
they do this by delivering a shallow
reductionist viewpoint that lets people
stoke a sense of pseudo-intellectual ism
and spares them from the pains of
contradiction to be found in many
worldviews many defenders of the school
of life might say that they are best
viewed as an introduction to philosophy
and a seven-minute video on Plato can't
possibly be expected to carry everything
that he said and I would agree with you
but that's not what bothers me about the
school of life's work the problem is
instead of conveying a true albeit
simplistic view of the philosophers
ideas many times instead they extract
the philosophers ideas and mash them
into their viewpoint until they resemble
some sort of self-help nonsense which is
not at all how the philosophers work was
meant to be taken for example with Plato
they can tort him into a dating coach
offering the following relationship
advice second big idea let your lover
change you that sounds weird if you
think that love means finding someone
who wants you just the way you are in a
symposium plato's play about a dinner
party where a group of friends drink too
much and get talking about love
sex and relationships Plato says true
love is admiration and on the surface it
seems like well yeah maybe Plato did say
that but the point is they're totally
contorting the author's working
achievements Plato's major contribution
to philosophy or his theories of form
dialectical method and political
theories not his thoughts in the ladies
if you're going to reduce a philosopher
down to seven minutes at least fill it
with their major contributions to the
philosophical world and sometimes they
do worse than this in this video
Ilan completely misunderstands the
mind-body problem which is the question
of how our mental thought and
consciousness controls our physical body
completely missing this instead Ilan
explains that wow it's a darn shame that
everyone judges you so much on your
looks instead of what's in your head the
so called mind-body problem is one of
the greatest and most quietly painful
conundrums in philosophy the problem is
rooted in the fact that in the eyes of
other people all of us are automatically
and stubbornly associated with our
bodies which includes of course our
faces and this kind of feel-good
philosophy is more than just unhelpful
its kind of productive because it can
cause people to think they possess an
understanding of philosophy when in
reality they have only been taught
shallow and disfigured elements of it
finally as if that wasn't all enough we
come to the third and final problem of
the school of life there hucksters and
profit tears they establish themselves
as some sort of guide of life and use
that position to sell merchandise that
is priced so high it borders on the
insane
how much would you say this imperfect
pot is worth it's literally a pot with
blemishes on it well it can be yours for
$75 or how about this regular candle
fifty dollars but best of all and so
telling of how money-grubbing this
operation really is is their
anti-capitalist notebooks which they
shamelessly ironically self with a very
Pro capitalistic price of twenty dollars
how to some of this video I think Alan
and his whole school of life is best
criticized through his own view of
business businesses should not he says
so desires but instead sell needs and
this is the crucial distinction he makes
between desires and needs a desire is
what you feel like you want at the
moment and a need is something that
serves your long-term well-being and I
think you're right alone so why in the
world are you selling a who should you
be with card game
for $15 I guess that that doesn't fall
under the need section for most people
and the same is true for their actual
content in the same way the School of
Life should stop selling the desires of
the people cheap watery self-help
philosophy drivel that reinforces their
belief system and instead sell to the
needs of the people
a real examination of what the
philosophers have been saying all along
and help explain how one best ought to
examine their lives because in the end
it's these true needs being met that
Plato and Aristotle would say produces a
life full of eudaimonia in other words a
life well-lived
[Music]